hanukkah the festival of lights is Rudy
levers chance to shine without his
dedication this celebration wouldn't be
taking place at all leather is the
chairman of the Bradford reform
synagogue and almost 90 years old the
Jewish community here is dwindled to
just 45 members yet the synagogue is
packed that's because Rudy hasn't only
invited people of the Jewish faith to
celebrate Hanukkah what is important for
Bradford for the Jewish community that
for once in a while and Hanukkah is the
best time to do it who invited people
from all religions and run and different
nationalities to meet together and lever
has done more than most to forge such
alliances in Bradford he's had to to
keep his small Jewish community alive in
changing times Bradford's Jewish
population has been dwindling for
decades and Muslims now make up close to
a quarter of the city's population for a
long time the two communities had little
to do with one another but that's all
changed hello oh are you well yes thank
you you that's also thanks to Jani
Rashid a Muslim who helped Rudy lever
save Bradford synagogue the synagogue
was in desperate need of repairs but the
Jewish community lacked the funds to pay
for them a Muslim neighbor heard of
their plight and made a generous
donation it was an extra surprise I mean
we were glad to get money from anywhere
which was always a surprise but they
came for the Muslims was a bigger
surprise that's quite true because
Bradford is certainly not free from
anti-semitism British newspaper The
Daily Mail filmed a Jewish person
wearing a kippah walking around the
streets of various British cities in
Bradford it took just minutes before he
was insulted as Jewish scum Rudy lever
and Jani Rasheed both agree that such
hostility is fueled by the conflict in
the Middle East they too have had to
make
huge leaps of faith they often meet to
talk things over in sweet Center a
pakistani indian restaurant around the
corner from the synagogue Zilpha Karim
is one of Bradford's most influential
muslims and one of levers biggest
supporters but he's had to defend his
actions even to himself was it right
spiritually morally all the questions
you asked yourself and also how would
the community feel that because don't
forget there's a lot of tensions out
there not not everything is his
beautiful and blue sky still levers
Muslim friends and neighbors want to do
everything possible to help I've never
seen a synagogue until already took me
in there and and to be honest videos for
us it was a an eye-opener the local
synagogue is part of our heritage in
city of Rochford they've been here
longer than us we won't we won't have
been here as a curry house for 50 years
and the synagogue has been here for more
than 200 years the relationship between
Rudy lever and his Muslim neighbors has
grown increasingly close still when the
Jewish leader asked jani Rashid to join
the synagogue's council in 2015 he was
surprised much it came a time that where
things were were not too good in the
Middle East in terms of relationships
between the Jerusalem was in community I
thought it was very brave of the Jewish
community at the synagogue and in
particular Rudy in having the the
foresight to sort of invite a non-jewish
person on to its its committee it would
be a means of cementing the cooperation
and friendship between Jews and Muslims
if we co-opted a Muslim onto the Council
of the synagogue
Andrew deal ever plans to keep on
cementing friendships between Bradford's
residents regardless of their religious
affiliation